mafia 3 screen shots taken from a
pre-alpha version of the game have
appeared online showing off a few
locales from the upcoming PlayStation 4
Xbox one and PC sequel I'm Dave and
welcome to enough for you gain reviews
gamespot news updates the images were
used by Seth rosin the game systems
designer as part of his GDC presentation
about bringing life to games with npc
behaviors to fit in with this theme the
shot offer an early look at the streets
of New Orleans with the game is set and
some eye-catching inside environments
too there are some really nice little
touches that can be seen in each image
to give life to the environment for
example shop windows and neon signs but
the streets feel moody while groups of
citizens make it look inhabited inside a
jazz bar a live band can be seen on
stage while patrons either watch or sit
off to the side enjoying drinks as
previously announced the game's
protagonist is Lincoln clay a mixed-race
man who grew up as an orphan and later
fought in the Vietnam War he returns to
New Orleans to establish a criminal
organization and oppose the Italian
mafia mafia 3 developer hangar 13 which
is a new studio established by 2k games
has said that the game will tackle
issues of racism and prejudice against
black people present in the deep south
during 1968 it will not however
sensationalize the issue of racism mafia
3 will be released sometime in 2016 but
publisher 2k games has not yet provided
a specific release date so are you
excited to step back into the shoes of a
made man are you worried you'll wake up
with a horse's head in your bed let us
know in the comments section below or
find me on twitter at arregle dave and
for all your mafioso news stay tuned to
gamespot com
you